well I unbalanced favor globalization I
think that the world is inextricably
interconnected and I think for example
trade that that treats the poorest
countries fairly or even preferentially
can make a huge difference in their
capacity to take care of themselves so I
favor globalization I am very critical
of the forms of protectionism that
really subvert globalization and I'll
give you one example agricultural
subsidies in the United States
subsidized very inefficient growers of
cotton in this country and allow them to
undersell in Africa cotton produced in
Africa that is of higher quality but
isn't subsidized and therefore is
undercut by American prices that seems
to me to be an example of where
globalization that is straightforward
and doesn't isn't distorted by unfair
subsidies would be much better for the
poorest countries than the kind of
system that we have now but overall I
think globalization is a potential and
often an actual positive what I think we
have to bring to the discussion of
globalization is the recognition that
the normal way that Westerners tend to
think of it that we Westerners think
about it namely as connecting
individuals uprooted from their
communities to each other the world over
is not the most constructive way to
think about globalization I think if
globalization is built from the ground
up people are members of communities and
it's important that those communities
that support individuals in their
efforts in turn are connected to wider
and wider circles of communities and
that leads to very different
prescriptions for globalization than if
we think in terms of atomistic
individuals who are related just
independently through markets or
bureaucracies rather than viewed as
embedded in their own communities so if
you go back to my description of the
national solidarity program or of honey
honey fought Mars Afghan a Public
Protection Force these are
all efforts to look at ways in which if
you start at the community level you can
build up to having viable participants
in globalization on a worldwide scale in
a way that you can't if you only focus
on individuals
well I think that the the book dead aid
is it has very interesting vignettes and
arguments within it but I think is is
basically flawed it it ret does not
recognize the extent to which assistance
appropriately deployed can lead to
building the kind of capacity that she
herself thinks is necessary for for a
country to get to the threshold where it
can access credit markets where it can
develop industry where it can engage in
trade and she has compelling vignettes
but the generalized prescription that
countries simply be expected to pull
themselves up by their bootstraps is one
that I think is simply not viable for
many of the countries that we are
working in I agree completely that it is
crucial not to encourage dependence on
aid and that's why from the very
beginning when we go into a situation we
work at building local capacity we have
we have 13,000 employees around the
world of the ones outside the United
States ninety-eight percent are locals
so it is not the case that we have a
heavy bureaucracy where we bring in very
expensive outsiders we do that only
initially in a process when they bring
skills that we need but their charge is
to train local so they develop capacity
so that when we leave a country which we
do after a certain period there there is
a kind of infrastructure of human
capital that we've helped to prepare
that's a appropriately deployed and that
it seems to me not to be subject to the
kinds of criticisms that she'd achieved
levels
you